what do we have here a Salvation Army
Santa notice anything weird he's black I
know I actually meant that he was shot
four times in the chest
that too poor baby looks like he stood
too close to someone under the mistletoe
it would appear so this is the fourth
santa in two weeks
well it looks like this killer
just made my Christmas wish list
[Music]
[Applause]
I already told you I was at a friend's
party that night you can ask him but you
had a shift at the store that night I
called in sick to go to a friend's house
all right I may have skipped work but
that doesn't make me a murderer no it
doesn't just a bad employee but why
could target kick out the Salvation Army
Santa's how should I know I'm just an
employee the higher-ups have their
political agenda and I don't ask
questions no it would appear you don't
listen I've answered your questions so
this is gonna go any further I want my
lawyer
[Music]
no need
you're free to go
[Music]
wait
[Music]
Merry Christmas happy holidays
[Music]
[Applause]
now you're going to tell me what
happened to those Santa's man I already
told you I don't know anything about
that
yes
you do know I don't yes you do no I
really don't yes look man I told you I
work at Walmart I don't work at target
target sucks is that so yeah man I said
look all right already something wrong
with you man you you like you're
[ __ ] or something if I were you I'd
watch my tongue or you might be
exchanging gifts this year behind bars
what this year it looks like you may
have a black-and-blue Christmas what do
we got so far well we're still looking
at the ballistics we've got the token
Latino guy working for prints and if
this killer left anything behind well I
guess let's all hope for a white
Christmas this year that didn't even
make sense
would you find huh oh absolutely nothing
but whoever pulled this off really hates
Christmas
oh my god epic novels Laura come with me
no I'm gonna stay here hey your
Christmas hating days are over
how'd you find out I know a Grinch when
I see one okay it's true I hate
Christmas but why the Salvation Army
Santa's oh come on you've been to the
stores with their Santa's and the ho ho
ho's and the ha ha ha and the merry
Christmas's and the god bless used it's
offensive but Christmas is about helping
out your fellow man listen we're
business and Santa's are bad for
business well I don't know how the
American people will feel about that
they are Christmas shoppers after all we
just want their money they can keep
their stupid holiday
no it's like somebody made the naughty
list
you stole my bed what I shot a man I get
to say the line don't steal my bed
and Merry Christmas
[Applause]